[Applaudissements]
sévrier 2012 abdelmadjid baraka devoir
risquer sa vie
depuis un an le peuple syriens
manifestent pour exiger des réformes
la répression du régime a déjà fait
plusieurs milliers de morts de son poste
aux premières loges du gouvernement
syrien
abdelmadjid a découvert les intentions
du régime ont souvent j'étais choqué par
la brutalité du gouvernement est encore
plus troublé de voir leur mépris de la
vie humaine pour les personnes tuées
n'était que des numéros
notre journaliste johan faucher et son
réalisateur le tremblay nous raconte
l'histoire de cet homme qui tente de
fuir son pays avec des documents
compromettants pour le gouvernement de
bachar al assad
s'il se fait prendre ils risquent la
torture ou même la mort
va-t-il réussir à passer la frontière
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
abdelmajid barakat décide de fuir la
série mais il ne part pas les mains
vides
il emporte avec lui des documents de la
cellule de gestion de crise dirigée par
le président bachar al assad
un passeur l'aide à fuir avec les
documents
il m'a dit que s'il m'aidait à m'enfuir
et que les documents étaient découverts
nous serions tous les deux assassinés
pour dissimuler des documents il l'école
sur sa poitrine son dos et ses jambes
puis il est camouflé sous son manteau je
réalisais que je faisais quelque chose
de très dangereux que je risquais de me
faire tuer le père a fait le trajet à
travers la syrie prendra deux jours sa
fuite peut être signalée à tout moment
aux différents postes de contrôle ce
qu'il craint le plus c'est de franchir
la frontière
comme je redoutais qu'ils me demandent
d'enlever mes vêtements et chevrolet
s'il me palper par dessus il ne se
sentirait rien tout va se jouer au poste
frontalier de bab al hawa qui sépare la
syrie et la turquie au moment où le
douanier maltais je craignais d'être
arrêtée à tout moment s'il avait mis sa
main sur mon coeur il n'aurait sentiers
que quelque chose n'allait pas mais il
ne l'a pas fait ça s'est bien passé
abdelmajid se réfugier à istanbul où ils
restent cachés pendant plusieurs mois il
est prudent conscient qu'il a avec lui
des preuves explosive contre bachar al
assad et son régime
le gouvernement sait maintenant qu'il
était une taupe au sein de la cellule de
crise
kannad je n'ai jamais souhaité faire ce
travailleur j'ai accepté cet emploi pour
pouvoir sortir ces documents
on est en compagnie de nos collègues le
réalisateur luc tremblay la journaliste
johan faucher johan n'est pas n'importe
qui convienne voir nom et travaillé
directement sous bachar al assad donc
c'était un témoin clé un témoin tu peux
aussi être assez jeune
d'ailleurs il avait toujours en turquie
et là bas le gouvernement le protège et
quand on est allé l'interviewer avec nos
collègues du fait de tester on pouvais
pas montrer le wild
mais malgré tout vous avez pu avoir
accès à ces documents secrets oui on les
a eus devant nous sur une table et je
peux vous dire qu'à ce moment là on
sentait pratiquement dans le bureau de
bachar al assad
[Musique]
c'est comme ça que c'était collet quand
je n'ai pas enlevé le ruban ici parce
que lorsque j'ai essayé ça s'est déchiré
tu ces documents étaient sur vous oui
sur ma poitrine dans mon dos et sur mes
jambes
un acompte je m'occupais de la gestion
des données des informations nous
devions recueillir les rapports
quotidiens provenant de la plupart des
centres de détention dans les 14
provinces ont trouvé dans ses rapports
toutes les données sur le nombre de
manifestations le nombre de manifestants
combien avaient été tués
combien étaient emprisonnés à 24 ans il
travaillait comme agent de bureau à la
cellule centrale de gestion de crise
un conseil de guerre composé de
ministres et de généraux qui avait comme
mandat de coordonner la répression bat
anatomy les dirigeants de la cellule
centrale de gestion de crise se
réunissaient tous les soirs un compte
rendu de la rencontre et des décisions
prises étaient envoyés à bachar al assad
directement vers 22 heures
je me souviens que lorsque les dossiers
lui était apportée au palais
présidentiel bachar al assad l'elysée
immédiatement les signets et nous les
renvoyer parfois il ajoutait aux
décisions prises
parfois ils enlevaient des choses qu'ils
avaient été décidés il savait combien il
y avait de manifestants il savait aussi
que plusieurs manifestants étaient
détenus ou tués il recevait ses
informations quotidiennement
ils nous montrent les documents ultra
secrets qu'elle a sortis clandestinement
ce document montre un décret adopté par
bachar al assad
à cette date il stipule que le fait que
trois personnes ou plus se trouvent
ensemble sur la rue peut être considérée
comme une émeute
le document est signé bachar al assad il
est clair selon cette directive datée
d'août 2011 que le président allait
tolérer aucune protestation contre son
gouvernement
les documents sont presque tous des
originaux les signatures à l'encré verte
sont celles des hauts dirigeants qui
faisait partie de la cellule centrale de
gestion de crise
il est étonnant que l'état ait fait
confiance à ce jeune universitaire qui
était un manifestant engagé avant d'être
embauché au gouvernement sur cette vidéo
il encourage des milliers de jeunes
syriens aient à participer au mouvement
de contestation
connu sous le nom de printemps arabe
après les tunisiens les égyptiens et les
libyens les syriens descente à leur tour
dans la rue et demandent pacifiquement
la fin de la corruption et plus de
libertés ça me donnait des ailes je me
sentais comme un oiseau qui s'en fout de
sa cage qui vole enfin librement quand
les manifestations commencées mahzen
alou mada était devant avec sa caméra
confiant de voir la syrie changé
technicien en ingénierie il avait de
très bons emplois dans l'industrie du
pétrole
il avait une famille une fiancée mais il
dit qu'il ne s'était jamais senti libre
[Musique]
nous avions l'espoir et le rêve
d'obtenir un pays démocratique
encadrés par une constitution mais nous
avons été déçus
cette vidéo d'une manifestation où il se
trouvait montre que là comme partout
ailleurs au pays
damas réprime rapidement tout espoir
un des documents dérobés par barakat
montre que le gouvernement a autorisé
des méthodes violentes dans au moins
trois villes les situations dans les
villes de homs hama et idlib doivent
être traités avec de nouveaux moyens par
l'utilisation de tireurs d'élite de
patrouille militaire dans les quartiers
de bombes lacrymogènes et en se
camouflant pour attaquer
ce qui est intéressant est ce qui est
assez rare c'est qu' il existe des
documents qui reflète des décisions
criminelle nous avons décidé de
s'attaquer tel dissidents de réprimer
telles manifestations violemment ça
normalement on n'a pas parce que ce sont
des choses qui transpire la criminalité
quand même il ya des preuves qui font le
lien entre les crimes et le chef de
l'état
l'avocat américain reed brody a
poursuivi en justice à augusto pinochet
jean claude duvalier et hissène habré on
le surnomme le chasseur de dictateur les
documents on les appelle les rois des
preuves parce que les documents
normalement ne mentent pas ils n'ont pas
de problèmes de mémoire
il perdure donc trente ans après quand
tous les témoins sont morts les
documents existent toujours
vous portez les documents générés par
les institutions qui ont commis les
crimes constitue de loin la meilleure
preuve qu'on puisse avoir dans une
enquête criminelle internationale
c'est de cette façon qu'on était monté
les dossiers contre les dirigeants nazis
à nuremberg
le premier témoignage entendu au
tribunal de nuremberg gh était celui de
l'archiviste en chef du régime nazi qui
était responsable de garder et de
classer les documents du régime l'ex
militaire canadien bien loi les sait à
quel point les documents sont importants
pour faire condamner un dictateur il a
été enquêteurs pour les tribunaux
internationaux au rwanda on a su que la
vie et en irak où il a travaillé aux
côtés des avocats de saddam hussein pour
s'assurer qu'il ait un procès juste et
équitable même si saddam hussein n'a pas
apprécié comme canadien se mêle de ses
affaires pearl oil et à fonder en 2011
si dja et comme il nous faut un
tenacement justice and accountability
nous sommes apolitiques nous ne
travaillons pas pour l'opposition
nous sommes neuf jours si dja est un
organisme privé sans but lucratif qui
s'est donné comme mission d'enquêté dès
maintenant sur les crimes commis par le
régime syrien
c'est la première fois qu'un organisme
qu ils soient internationales nationales
ou privées mène une enquête au milieu
d'un conflit armé d'une telle intention
si les documents perdus
il pourra aussi disparaître si j'ai
l'air hamas maintenant je les garde dans
un temps ces documents seront
disponibles
mais si je ne ramasse pas aujourd'hui
dans 20 ans joran 10 parle si dja est
une opération tellement secrète que nous
ne pouvons pas vous dire dans quel pays
ils sont aucune affiche à la porte
d'entrée ni de site web
les documents sont scannés analysés par
des professionnels qu'on ne peut
identifier
christine chose est un des seuls qui
acceptent de révéler son identité
c'est sa première entrevue à la
télévision nous ne payons pas pour
obtenir des documents ni pour des
témoignages les gens qui collaborent
avec nous le font parce qu'ils croient à
la valeur de notre objectif qui est de
monter des dossiers criminels
abdelmajid barakat connaît la valeur de
ces documents il les garde dans un
coffre fort dans une bande d'istanbul et
avisent les autorités turques
chaque fois qu'il descend c'est ce que
j'ai fait quand les gens de sinjar sont
venus me rencontrer
nous avons passé trois jours dans une
chambre d'hôtel ils ont regardé les
documents les ont photographié et les
ont analysés
s'écrie san jose qui a rencontré
abdelmajid barakat c'est le contenu de
ces documents est le fait que barakat
puisse témoigner personnellement de
comment cette information a été corrigé
et qu'il a reçue en font une preuve très
percutante
depuis 2011 le soulèvement populaire
syrien s'est progressivement transformée
en guerre civile le régime affronte
plusieurs groupes rebelles mais ils
continuent d'attaquer des civils
la ville d'alep a été assiégé la
population affamée l'hôpital dar al
shifa a été bombardé plusieurs fois ils
ont attaqué l'hôpital plus de dix fois
l'édifice avait neuf étages
chaque fois qu'il y avait un
bombardement un étage était d'être à
jeun travaillait comme bénévole à
l'urgence de l'hôpital d'alès pour cette
raison il est arrêté en octobre 2013 à
un poste de contrôle et voulaient que je
leur donne les noms des médecins et des
infirmières qui travaillent à l'hôpital
il voulait aussi les noms du personnel
d'autres hôpitaux et les coordonnées des
hôpitaux clandestins pour pouvoir les
cibler
en un instant la vie de cette étudiante
universitaire en éducation a basculé
dans un enfer elle a été déplacée
secrètement d'une prison à une autre
pendant dix mois mes parents ignoraient
où j'étais ce qui m'était arrivé ils
croyaient que j'étais morte parce que
c'est ce qu'on leur a répondu quand ils
m'ont cherché cette jeune fille est
arrivée à montréal comme réfugié en
décembre dernier nous avons changé son
nom parce qu'elle craint les
représailles contre sa famille restée en
syrie la nomme maven vacallo les curieux
lorsque je repense à cette période j'ai
l'impression que c'est un rêve je
n'arrive pas à croire que j'ai vécu cela
et que je m'en suis sorti
mazen à l'houmeau da a été arrêté alors
qu'il s'apprêtait à livrer du lait
maternisé dans un quartier assiégé par
le régime
il a été torturé à répétition ils ont
détruit mes beaux souvenirs détruit mon
enfance ma jeunesse
ils ont complètement détruit
je poursuis mon travail pour survivre
pour me convaincre que je suis un être
humain digne qui a son jugement
ces valeurs un sens moral et éthique
le portrait qu'assad fait de nous un
faux nous sommes des gens éduqués des
universitaires il nous a tué et détruit
tout ce que nous avions envie je veux
que ceux qui nous écoutent comprennent
que nous sommes des êtres humains juste
des êtres humains
[Musique]
je
dans la suite de notre enquête
un autre syrien va réussir à sortir des
preuves des atrocités commises dans la
prison où ont été torturées mazen
[Musique]
comme mahzen et zen des dizaines de
milliers de syriens ont été emprisonnés
dans un des 27 centres de détention
dirigé par l'armée et les services de
renseignement ils portent pour la
plupart des numéros 227 215 à 245 un de
ceux à la plus sinistre réputation
le 235 le centre palestine le centre de
détention palestine est le plus grand de
cela on les appelle les prisons de la
mort la plupart des gens qui meurent en
détention était dans une centrale ils
sont plus horrible que les autres années
zen a passé six mois à la prison
palestine à votre avis
les séances de torture ont commencé dès
mon arrestation à alep et se sont
poursuivis au centre de détention
militaire comme ils m'ont frappé avec
des barres de métal des câbles qu'un
fake halal je fais encore des cauchemars
où je revis ce que j'ai vu et entendu au
centre de détention
les bruits que j'entendais lorsque les
gardiens fracasser la tête des jeunes
hommes contre les murs de ma cellule
parfois j'entends des leurs ou craquer
et plusieurs en sont morts je les
entendais agoniser et leur sang coulait
jusque sous la porte pour sa part mahzen
s'est retrouvé à la prison de l'aéroport
de meadows est un nom qui inspire la
peur aux syriens faciale ronnie lequel
son apogée cours ils m'ont enlevé mon
survêtement bakari koné et ils ont mis
comme une sorte d'étau autour de mon
pénis ils ont serré serré et serré
jusqu'à ce que je ne sens plus rien qui
al'air parole pendant ce temps un autre
officier me sodomisé avec un bâton
ils ont fait des choses impensables pour
un être humain
après des mois de détention et de
torture mahzen est envoyé à l'hôpital
six ans le lendemain vers 10 heures
ils m'ont sorti du centre de détention
ils m'ont dit oublies ton nom tu n'es
plus mazana le goût madame qui n'est
plus que le numéro 1858 parce que quand
les gens meurent ils portent un numéro
sur leurs fronts d'abord à l'hôpital
militaire 601 est un endroit où l'on
massacre et tuent les prisonniers at-on
ou à construire a demandé mais elle le
découvre en se rendant aux toilettes en
ouvrant la porte des toilettes
j'ai vu des cadavres empilés les uns sur
les autres je croyais rêver
je me suis frotté les yeux quand je les
ai ouvert
j'ai remarqué que certains cadavres
étaient mutilés différentes parties du
corps manquaient pour certains c'était
lui
mazet n'a été torturé presque tous les
jours pendant un an et sept mois
à sa sortie de prison il porte les
marques des menottes avec lesquels il a
été suspendu des brûlures de cigarettes
sur ses jambes
c'est tellement horrible qu'on a du mal
à imaginer que des e-mails puisse
infliger ça à d'autres humains on va
maintenant vous présenter un autre
syrien qui est travaillé dans les
couloirs de la mort et qui a lui aussi
décidé de fuir avec des preuves
compromettantes
on est mieux vous prévenir certaines
images sont très dur mais c'est la
réalité et ces gens là prennent des
risques
justement pour que ça vous touche et que
ça arrête l'homme à droite cacher sous
l'imperméable bleus était un militaire
qui travaillait dans la prison où ont
été torturées mahzen
pendant deux ans sa tâche était de
photographier les corps de ceux qui
mouraient les collègues et moi et s'ils
ont sidéré par ce que nous avions je
rends les yeux c'est cet homme se fait
appeler césar pour des raisons de
sécurité il refuse qu'on montre son
visage et même qu'on enregistre sa voix
il chuchote ses réponses à l'interprète
nous avons tous eu envie de déserter sur
le champ ce qui nous a retenu c'est
notre désir de rester pour pouvoir
révéler au monde entier la méchanceté et
l'inhumanité de ces personnes
pipeau après deux ans et s'enfuit
finalement avec 55 mille photos copié
sur des clés usb qu'il cachait chaque
jour dans ses chaussures si j'avais été
surpris en possession des copies de ces
photos ça aurait été le dernier jour de
ma vie los angels expliquent les trois
numéros que l'on retrouve sur les photos
des onze mille cadavres
le numéro de détenu celui du centre de
détention et le numéro 17
la machine infernale de tortures et
d'exécutions est érigée en système
suivant les lois de la bureaucratie
selon césar ces photos consignées dans
des registres permettait au régime de
savoir que les ordres avaient été
exécutés pour la loi note chose je veux
montrer cette machine meurtrière qui
massacrent et élimine des êtres humains
au vu et au su du monde entier
les photos de césar ont été
authentifiées en laboratoire par le fbi
des pathologistes les ont également
examiné et conclut que les corps et
massy sont ceux de détenus battus avec
brutalité étrangler mutilés et affamés à
mort
il en faut apparemment plus pour
émouvoir bachar al assad
un journaliste américain lui montre des
photos prises par césar if you take
disposent ni carte ni au conflit good
des compétiteurs mais je suis convaincu
à 100% de la responsabilité de bachar al
assad
ils recevaient non seulement les
rapports de la cellule centrale de
gestion crise mais aussi ceux de tous
les départements de police en syrie
bachar al assad a probablement raison
sur un point les photos de césar ne
suffiront pas il faudra avoir le
portrait complet pour pouvoir le
condamner c'est justement ce que le
canadien bear loyal et s'acharne à faire
établir les liens entre ceux qui
commettent les crimes dans les prisons
et lui le président le régime syrien
ressemble à tous les régimes
il y a beaucoup de paperasse en irak par
exemple nous avions accès à des millions
de pages de documents
mais on ne retrouve jamais écrit noir
sur blanc l'ordre de commettre des actes
criminels du style tu es moi ces
dissidents ou je veux que la torture
soient systématiquement utilisés dans
nos prisons il faut alors se concentrer
à reconstruire la chaîne de commandement
et la structure de communication des
institutions qui commettent les crimes
nous mettons beaucoup d'efforts à
essayer d'établir comment les centres de
détention relève d'une série d'autorités
locales puis comment ces entités locales
relève ultime en des institutions à
damas c'est demain
si jo ne se contente pas de recevoir des
documents de fugitifs sais rien ils
mènent leurs propres opérations sur le
terrain
n'est ce pas lorsque le régime perd du
terrain les forces gouvernementales
s'enfuit et laissent des documents
derrière aussitôt que le régime
abandonne une position nous avons une
chance d'aller récupérer ces documents
dans un instant on faisait mais nos
coeurs d'opérations ultra secrète pour
récupérer des milliers de documents
derrière la ligne de front en syrie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la majorité des employés de cydia ne
travaille pas au siège social
ils sont une centaine d'agents sur le
terrain
déployé en syrie malgré la guerre
prépare la prochaine opération sur le
terrain
notre équipe travaille en zone de guerre
où il est impossible de garantir la
sécurité absolue
nos agents sur le terrain pourrait
quitter la syrie mais il décide chaque
jour de rester pour faire ce travail
chaque jour ils évaluent si ce que nous
essayons d'accomplir vaut la peine de
courir autant de risques et il décide de
rester ils sont un atout extrêmement
précieux l'enquêteur en série parle
arabe crise a donc recours aux services
d'un interprète leur travail dangereux
et nous devons modifier leur voix chaque
chargement de documents qu'ils soient de
40 ou de 400 kg est une histoire unique
en soi mais la clé de notre succès
repose d'abord et avant tout sur les
relations que nous avons ici avec
certains groupes armés en syrie
non pas avec des ch bien entendu ni avec
jabba fin nous sera non
quand des groupes rebelles gagnent du
terrain les employés du gouvernement
syrien s'enfuient laissant derrière lui
des tonnes de documents militaires et de
renseignement
souvent les preuves ne sont accessibles
que pour un court laps de temps
si on n'agit pas à ce moment elle nous
échappe parce qu il leur faut donc faire
vite et bien
il faut s'assurer qu'une fois rendus en
cours nous soyons capables d'établir
d'où vient chaque document et par où il
a transité des dans un premier temps les
documents sont caché en lieu sûr en
série jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient
sécuritaires de les sortir du pays pour
traverser des zones de combats passés
des postes de contrôle militaires
les documents sont camouflés dans des
valises et des boîtes de bananes nous
évaluons constamment le niveau de danger
nous voulons que justice soit faite mais
sans prendre des risques démesurés pour
y arriver nous ne voulons pas agir
encore boy et mettre la vie de nos
employés en péril une institution privée
peut prendre des risques que les nations
unies que la cour pénale internationale
ne peut prendre
ils ont beaucoup moins de contraintes
diplomatiques ou bureaucratiques
mais si dieu a subi des pertes ainsi
rien qu'ils participaient à un convoi a
été tuée en revenant d'une mission en
d'autres ont été blessées certains ont
été capturée et relâchée
tous les documents sortis
clandestinement de série sont gardés
dans cet endroit secret la preuve pour
poursuivre le régime syrien de crimes
contre l'humanité et dans ces boîtes 750
mille documents
plus de trois tonnes de papiers des
procès verbaux des rapports
gouvernementaux les mandats d'arrêt et
de détention de milliers de syriens
peu de gens ont accès à cette voûte même
belloy les doit signer pour sortir les
documents qu'elle veut nous montrer de
stork deux formes
ce document date du 10 avril 2011
il est signé par bachar al assad
commandant en chef des armées
il autorise le temps supplémentaire aux
militaires qui doivent travailler de
longues heures pour en termes
diplomatiques répondre ou manifestations
même un document portant sur le temps
supplémentaire peut servir dans un
procès criminel
ce document est très important parce que
l'ordre vient directement de bachar al
assad
cette pièce montre qu'il exerçait
réellement un contrôle direct sur
l'armée dans une poursuite criminelle
il est essentiel de prouver que bachar
al assad a de réels pouvoirs
lundi à mardi je n'ai aucun espoir parce
qu'il n'y a pas de justice
après tout ce qu'il a fait bachar al
assad est toujours libre
et il poursuit ses crimes zen et mahzen
ne demande pas un procès pour leurs
bourreaux quand ils ne connaissent même
pas le nom les hauts dirigeants entraîne
ses soldats qui sont leurs esclaves ils
devraient être menotté et jugés comme
des criminels nous devons juger ce qui
leur donne l'ordre de tuer de brûler et
d'éliminer les détenus ouattara ni avec
les documents numérisés
sidya a constitué une immense base de
données on y retrouve des milliers de
noms dont celui de mazen aussi on voit
ici le nom complet de mazen et nous
avons une date janvier 2012
toi nous n'avons pas toute la chaîne de
documents dans ce cas mais nous pouvons
déduire que juste avant ce document si
un ordre a été donné de trouver ce gars
est de le jeter entre à la suite du
mandat d'arrestation mahzen a bel et
bien été arrêtés et torturés mais qui en
a donné l'ordre
pour mazen et pour les milliers d'autres
si jack quoi être en mesure de prouver
la responsabilité criminelle de toute la
chaîne de commandement du régime syrien
dans ce document si un commandant donne
l'ordre qui est ensuite relayés à toutes
les unités qui sont sous son
commandement d'arrêter d'utiliser
certaines méthodes d'interrogatoire
musclées
il fait référence particulièrement à la
pratique de brûler les détenus avec des
cigarettes
ils demandent aussi et je cite d'arrêter
de forcer les détenus à s'asseoir sur
des bouteilles de boissons gazeuses plus
vraisemblablement en demande au gardien
d'arrêter de [__] les détenus avec
ses bouteilles
le commandant semble prendre des mesures
pour protéger les détenus
ce n'est pas suffisant ce n'est pas une
preuve de son innocence
dans les faits c'est le contraire ce
document démontre que les hauts gradés
savent que des crimes sont commis et
cette connaissance créé pour eu
l'obligation légale d'y mettre fin ce
n'est pas suffisant de demander
d'arrêter si dans les faits les
comportements criminels continue et on
peut condamner quelqu'un non pas parce
que il a donné l'ordre de torturer mais
parce qu'il savait que ont torturé que
ces âmes torturées et qui n'est pas
intervenue soit pour empêcher swapo
punir belloy aller nous a montré
plusieurs autres documents qui
pourraient prouver la culpabilité des
hauts gradés
tous ces exemples sont de très très bons
éléments pour bâtir une preuve contre la
hiérarchie
ils ne peuvent pas plaider l'ignorance
et ne peuvent pas non plus clamer qu'il
n'avait aucun moyen pour faire enquête
sur ces abus qui leur étaient rapportés
je pense que peut-être dans l'histoire
de l'humanité
il n'y a pas de situation criminelle
aussi bien documenté que la série avec
les documents avec les photos avec les
insider donc des personnes qui avaient
travaillé pour les régimes qui sont à
l'extérieur il serait difficile de
penser à notre situation où la masse des
preuves et est aussi solide en temps
réel que ce qu'on vit actuellement un
sérieux
au retour il y aura-t-il un procès pour
bachar al assad
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait maintenant plus de cinq ans
qu'abdel majid barakat s'est enfui de la
série avec des documents collé sur la
peau il aa de témoigner devant un juge
c'est une question très importante au
début de la révolution
on se demandait si notre travail serait
un sacrifice ponctuelle ou celui de
toute une vie si bachar al-assad reste
au pouvoir
est ce que tout ça n'aura finalement
servi à rien vous collectez des
documents depuis cinq ans six ans
maintenant environ cinq ans oui
êtes vous prêt à présenter les documents
devant un tribunal
absolument nous avons eu huit ou neuf
dossiers prêts pour la cour des dossiers
qui met en cause les plus hautes sphères
du régime syrien incluant le président
al-assad tout ce qui nous manque pour
aller de l'avant
c'est un procureur pour présenter la
cause est un tribunal pour nous entendre
aussi le problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas
de tribunal international prêt à juger
bachar al assad
quand césar a rendu publiques ces photos
et s'attendait ce que la communauté
internationale réagisse déçu et
l'implorent le comité du congrès
américain de mettre fin à la tuerie
nous avons la responsabilité de sauver
ceux qui sont toujours détenus dans les
prisons d'assad
ce qu'on voit sur les photos n'en sont
jamais sortis mais il faut tout faire
pour s'assurer que d'autres ne subissent
pas le même
horrible sort les photos sorties
clandestinement par césar ont été
exposés à washington bruxelles et aux
nations unies les tentatives de
poursuivre le régime syrien devant la
cour pénale internationale se sont butés
au veto de la chine et de la russie
c'est l'impasse pour le peuple syrien ce
n'est pas frustrant c'est extrêmement
frustrant surtout pour nos employés
syriens qui sont sur le terrain ils sont
extrêmement épuisé et surtout exaspérés
par l'absence de résultats
malheureusement malheureusement malgré
tous les changements qui ont été opérés
ces dernières années avec la cour pénale
internationale avec le rwanda la
yougoslavie hissène habré etc
il est toujours vrai que la grande
majorité des des massacres et des actes
de torture sont impunis si je travaille
secrètement avec plusieurs pays
européens qui mènent des enquêtes
judiciaires contre le régime syrien
un organisme privé comme le nôtre ne
peut pas se substituer aux institutions
judiciaires ne pouvons pas porter
d'accusation nous ne pouvons que faire
enquête
si déjà a été conçu pour servir d'outil
aux autorités publiques
une douzaine de pays sont en contact
avec sidya à toutes les deux semaines
nous recevons la visite à nos bureaux de
policiers et de procureurs de ces pays
qui viennent prendre connaissance des
preuves que nous avons c'est déjà refuse
de dire avec quel pays il collabore mais
nous savons que l'allemagne est en
contact avec une des causes qui est sur
le bureau de la justice là bas
concernent des accusations criminelles
portées par des réfugiés syriens en
allemagne je vais dresser un portrait
global du système syrien au procureur
pour expliquer que les disparitions et
la torture sont systématiques et remonte
à longtemps
anwar al bunni a été incarcéré pendant
cinq ans parce que défend des les droits
de l'homme en syrie
aujourd'hui il collabore avec une ong
allemande qui soutient le recours contre
six hauts gradés syrien soupçonné de
torture et de crimes contre l'humanité
pour qu'il y ait un procès en allemagne
les accusés devront être ici ce qui
n'empêche pas l'anc est de se poursuivre
et de lancer éventuellement des mandats
d'arrêt contre ces personnes
même si elles ne sont pas ici
[Musique]
puisque les six accusés sont toujours en
syrie le recours a plutôt valeur de
symbole
le message qu'on envoie ces personnes
c'est vous ne pouvez plus à l'est où
vous voulez ce que vous avez fait est
inacceptable
à ces gens seront qu'ils sont recherchés
que leur possibilité de se déplacer est
limité et que tout ça est une
conséquence directe des actes qu'ils ont
commis en syrie ça fait six ans que je
travaille à la poursuite des criminels
de guerre en europe l'un je suis
découragé il n'y a pas de volonté de
chercher ce qui se cache en europe
le problème c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
vraiment les ressources pour faire ça et
c'est là que si déjà prend toute son
importance
je suis convaincu qu'on verra des
arrestations cette année belloy aller
est aussi convaincu que ses dirigeants
syriens qui se cache en europe seront
accusés nous savons qu'un certain nombre
de hauts gradés qui auraient commis des
crimes se trouvent en europe
présentement les poursuivre en justice
enverrait le message aux syriens qui lie
à une justice en quelque part
en attendant un éventuel procès si dja
doit s'assurer de garder le soutien de
ses bailleurs de fonds son financement
dépend de plusieurs pays dont le canada
qui accorde un peu plus de 2 millions
par année belloy l ai rencontré en
juillet dernier à ottawa
des fonctionnaires des affaires
mondiales le canadien reste convaincu
que bachar al assad sera jugé je ne
crois pas que bachar al assad continuera
à diriger la science s'il survit à la
guerre l'histoire nous enseigne que tôt
ou tard il sera arrêté et jugé
c'est ce qui est arrivé à slobodan
milosevic en serbie giles taylor au
liberia saddam hussein en irak et à
laurent gbagbo de côte d'ivoire
ils ont tous fini en prison pourquoi est
ce que ce serait différent pour assad
[Musique]
la vie de ceux qui ont sorti des preuves
contre le régime syrien est en suspens
césar vie cachée quelque part en europe
de son côté abdel majid barakat est
toujours réfugié en turquie sous la
protection du gouvernement
ils refusent l'idée qu'il est risqué sa
vie en vain pour révéler au monde les
atrocités du régime syrien mais qu'elle
fait lorsque la révolution a commencé
nous avons cru que chacun devait faire
sa part pour y arriver même un simple
sacrifices
j'étais convaincu que j'arriverai à
sortir de syrie vers la turquie pour
révéler le vrai visage du régime
j'étais sûr que les documents changerait
l'opinion de ceux qui supportent le
régime et qu'il comprendrait que ce sont
des criminels
les témoins sont vivants les documents
en sécurité
reste à attendre le vert' et de
l'histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est de retour avec la conclusion de
l'émission
johan des gens qui ont subi ce que vous
montrez dans votre reportage ce soir il
y en a ici à montréal
quand j'ai commencé mes recherches pensé
que ce serait difficile moi de trouver
des gens qui ont subi la torture permet
les réfugiés syriens qui viennent
d'arriver
pourtant ça m'a pris que quelques coups
de téléphone jeudi on vous a présenté le
témoignage de zen mais on a aussi parlé
afin dé à basel les histoires tout aussi
horrible
surtout il faut pas oublier que ça
continue au moment où on se parle il ya
des gens qui sont torturés dans les
prisons d'hassaba oui c'est ça qu'on a
tendance à oublier alors merci de nous
avoir apporté ce témoignage là c'est
important merci d'avoir été là c'est
tout pour cette semaine et revenez nous
la semaine prochaine pour une autre
enquête
[Musique]
à